we went out and pitched it around town
and had one buyer which was Netflix so
only one buyer only one buyer wait wait
how many did you pitch right pitched
five at least and they all said no and
yeah so it was Miles myself and two
other writers that's expensive yeah yeah
no it was not cheap and and it was and
it became the first Zoom room because we
started the week of lockdown literally
which feels writing a show about
Wednesday Adams during a global pandemic
feels on brand so you know
um yeah so we so we basically broke out
the rest of the season had had written
at that point
four and four or five more scripts and
we knew okay if we're gonna go out with
this again as a bigger so round two of
pitching round two of pitching we need a
we need a big director element and Tim
was always at the top of our list